you
you
Richard I'm just going to ask you a few
questions about tallish and you've
growing up here and what you kind of do
at the moment yeah well I've lived in
dawlish for the last 25 years and I paid
a decorator me and my partner Kimberly
we've been saving now for some time for
to buy a house and this opportunity to
Rose and yeah we're going to take it
with both hands fantastic so where are
you currently living them well we live
with our parents and stay with each
other on the odd occasion and yeah just
really we've just been saved all our
money we haven't had to have the expense
of renters and we're really expensive so
we're lucky in that respect so yeah
we're just really really really grateful
for this opportunity like a serger so
how did you find out about these homes
here with Cornerstone well basically
went when Barrett's put in the planning
I got onto the council to find out who
the actual housing association was going
to be that was kind of be dealing with
the houses and it was cornerstone and so
I got into the telephone with
Cornerstone and don't you just go
through the application process and yeah
here we are today fantastic um what sort
of issues of you face then as you've
sort of tried to get on the housing
ladder and wanting to sort of stay and
live in the area always lived in the
affordability that's one house is really
expensive we can afford one saving the
deposit that's another and also getting
the mortgage that's just a nightmare
getting the mortgage yeah so so yeah but
like I say there's only free part
ownership houses being built on this
whole state which isn't really enough I
appreciate there's some rented but it
just gives you a real good opportunity a
real good start yeah I step on the
ladder of that people do need so yes
it's really important is a really
important thing and how did it feel
walking around today and seeing their
houses go up and taking shape you know
it's actually yeah here you go where
it's going to be yours so it's like yeah
it's real yes really it gets really
excited really so were any other
opportunities like this around here or
or was this the first thing that's sort
of suitable for beauty well between i
would say X minster and newton abbot as
far as i know this is the only sort of
thing that's going on in this area
especially the part ownership I do
believe we're going to be building some
up in x-men stir in the future and in
dawlish there was a there was a site in
timber that was doing the part ownership
but now that's Philip filled up and thus
finished so yeah this is the only thing
in this area so it's really important
like look lovely said before but yeah as
far as I notice is the only site
subscribe to say there's few and far
between them opportunity like this so
this property is called shoreland house
and is owned and managed by cornerstone
housing it was bought in 2007 from Devon
County Council and had been empty for a
year or over a year and was sort of a
bit of an eyesore formerly a caretakers
launcher a man named Stan Shaolin lived
here for a number of years with his
family and was the caretaker of the
local school hence the name shoreland
house and cornerstone in partnership
with team bridge district council on the
Homes and Communities Agency transformed
this redundant building in 28
one-bedroom flats for local people in
dawlish
redrock is a fantastic resource because
it provides the opportunity for young
people from 14 to 16 to actually become
skilled and trained in with a kind of
occupations and jobs that are needed for
the local economy in local area it goes
to show that when you have really good
resources equipment facilities and
excellent tutors put young people in
that environment that can only be
successful what we'll see here today is
young people who were actually in school
still in schools but had never worked in
the constructional catering or I had
just seen areas and within two terms of
this course they become incredibly
skilled and could enter the workplace
with any difficulty at the end of the
two years that's important because not
only does it provide people skilled
adults to become employees but also mode
spaces young people through their school
for us
okay what's up a job would you like to
have once you leave full-time schooling
working my own salon by to my own
business you know just generally working
with working with people what types of
jobs do you think there should be more
of locally start like like in shops
stuff where you can travel something
places like this you know like helping
young people like ourselves do you see
yourself living and working in the door
share in the future maybe for the first
part but long-term I'd like to move out
because and what do you think is
stopping people what the barriers are
stopping people getting jobs locally
it's not enough there's not enough money
there's not enough places a lot of
houses where they can live an assist
there's no nothing anything and why is
it good being to get your skills
training locally here at Red Rock
because we don't have to have the grades
to you know go to college and and it's
the NIP like white boy opposite our
school so they have to travel far and
what are the types of skills training do
you think should be provided here for
example you're doing here dressing what
other things might you be interested in
where your friends be interested in
fashion Fitness things like like that
like cooking and they are so in just
music and how important do you think it
is the training you're getting now will
be in getting you to get a good job so
you get an income to be able to rent or
buy your own house locally but it's very
important because you know we dweet but
Lisa teaches us to know how to behave
how to know do that and work in a salon
and you know make our money
you
you